the year 2020 might feel far away right
now but that hasn't stopped Hollywood's
major studios from lining up a slew of
projects to compete for your movie
budget even a couple of years out some
of the upcoming releases on the calendar
are highly anticipated sequels but that
isn't all we're expecting to see the
studio's have also set up new
adaptations of existing properties and
all manner of would-be blockbusters
making for what should be an epic year
at the movies start marking your
calendar now we've rounded up an
in-depth look at the biggest releases
coming along in 2020 bad boys for life
17 years after the release of bad boys
to audiences we'll finally get another
entry in the buddy-cop franchise the
film brings back Will Smith and Martin
Lawrence's Miami detectives Mike Lowrey
and Marcus Burnett and the two couldn't
be more excited about working together
again making movies we're gonna do it
while it's been a bumpy road to get the
film to the greenlight it's full speed
ahead for the duo now and a release date
has been set for January 17 GI Joe
ever-vigilant seven years after GI Joe
retaliation everyone's favorite action
figure based franchise is set to return
it's unclear which if any of the
original movie stars will return as it's
rumored to be a reboot but considering
the original cast included everyone from
Channing Tatum to Bruce Willis to Dwayne
the rock Johnson it's hard to imagine we
wouldn't see at least some of those
a-listers on the Call Sheet when movie 3
gets ready for a March 27th debut fast
and furious 9 by the time Fast and
Furious 9 comes along fans of the speedy
franchise will have gotten their first
spin-off featuring Dwayne Johnson and
Jason Statham although we don't know
much about where the sagas headed next
the pressure to keep upping the stakes
should mean it'll find a way to be even
more epic than previous installments
with Charlize Theron 'he's ciphers still
alive and on the loose at the end of
fate of the furious there are lots of
opportunities for mayhem you can
probably count on most of your favorite
cast members returning and the
franchise's ever-increasing profile
means there's always the chance they'll
land even more big names to join the
family audiences will definitely want to
drive out to the theater on April 10th
Godzilla vs. Kong film fans will finally
get the answer to the age-old question
of which movie monster reigns supreme
when Godzilla and King Kong faceoff on
the big screen director Adam Wingard has
already assured fans that his take on
the two monsters will crown a definitive
winner
unlike the 1962 film that first put the
two characters against each other
although we still don't know which
actors will be part of the fun there are
sure to be some a listers on board when
this epic behemoth battle barrels into
the summer box office on May 22nd the
six billion dollar man Mark Wahlberg
will help breathe cinematic life into
the 70s small screen series the Six
Million Dollar Man by giving the
character arrays to the six billion
dollar man Wahlberg will play Steve
Austin a former astronaut who uses
cutting-edge technology to become half
machine in order to survive after an
accident and uses his newfound
superhuman strength to work as a secret
agent working for the office of
scientific intelligence with its mix of
robotics espionage and brute physical
force the six billion dollar man should
be an event when it comes along On June
5th red notice Dwayne Johnson is set to
reap team with director rawson marshall
thurber after working together on
Central Intelligence and skyscraper for
2020s action comedy film red notice the
movie will feature Johnson as an
Interpol agent chasing after the most
wanted art thief in the world
we'll see if the rock maintains his
magic streak at the movies when red
notice hits theaters on June 12th
Indiana Jones 5 this installment of the
Indiana Jones films won't feature any
less lined refrigerators or ill
explained aliens so if you weren't a fan
of kingdom of the Crystal Skull the
franchise's newest outing will get
things back on track for you everyone
involved seems to think the movie will
be a course correction with Harrison
Ford saying he only wanted to return if
the script was great
and Steven Spielberg saying he thinks
the movie is quote straight down the
pike for the fans it's great fun to play
this character it's great fun to work
with Steven I'm looking forward to
there's a lot of potential for the
future of the franchise
and the next film seems like it could
bring back the adventure of the original
trilogy when it arrives on July temp
bios Tom Hanks will be the last man on
earth in this sci-fi outing specific
plot details for BIOS are being kept
tightly under wraps but we do know that
Hanks character Finch is an ailing
inventor and the last man left on this
planet who builds a robot to protect his
beloved dog after his death although we
don't have any concrete details yet
Hanks has shown us many many times that
he's the right guy to lead up any kind
of survival story even completely solo
so count on this one to be a must-watch
on October 2nd fantastic beasts 3 while
we're still waiting to see what happens
in the second fantastic beasts and where
to find the movie Warner Brothers is
already gearing up for the third film in
the franchise very little is known about
the film at this point but the series
definitely got off to an encouraging
start for the first film earning solid
reviews and healthy box office returns
with the second movie bringing in even
more Harry Potter connections and the
third likely to build on that further
November 20th is a date you'll want to
pencil in on your calendar for more
movie magic to come avatar - we're
getting for Avatar sequels over the next
decade so a lot rides on the first one
doing well when it hits theaters in 2020
James Cameron's massive undertaking
reportedly has a total budget of over 1
billion dollars allowing the director to
fully embrace new technology and make
sure that the sequels are as visually
stunning as the first chapter the movies
are said to be a family saga about Jake
materi and their children with many of
the film's original cast returning as
well newcomers to the franchise include
Cliff Curtis and Oona Chaplin as
additions to the Pandora collective
which will return to theaters December
18th Sherlock Holmes 3 Robert Downey jr.
is set to return for a third outing as
the world's most famous detective in a
film that will also feature the return
of his co-star Jude Law as John Watson
it's unclear if Guy Ritchie who directed
the first two films will return but
since it's been nine years since Downey
last played the character in a game of
shadow
it should be interesting to see how his
take on Sherlock Holmes is aged when
this new leg of the adventure hits
theatres December 25th
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 last but
certainly not least Marvel is expected
to bring back their intergalactic team
of misfits with guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 it's unclear who will return
following the events of Avengers
infinity war but we do know it's
supposed to offer an epic conclusion to
the saga of the star Lords ragtag
squadron while helping to potentially
launch the next phase of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
[Music]